[Norvig] In this quiz we're going to consider each of the shuffle routines--
that is, the shuffle routine coming from Knuth, the Algorithm P,
the shuffle1 that was the teacher's original shuffle,
and the shuffle2 and 3 that we just saw.
And for each of them I want you to tell me,
is the runtime order N or order N squared,
and is the result that we get back correct
in the sense that all outcomes are equally probable?
We already know that the shuffle routine is order N and it is correct,
and we know that shuffle1 is order N squared and it's not correct.
And now what I want you to tell me is for shuffle2 and 3
what's the order of complexity, and is it correct?
If so, hit this check button.